on this thanksgiving eve a story of loss
but also gratitude
a widow whose husband died of covid19
reunites with the healthcare workers who
took care of them
the i-team's vanessa murphy shares this
story you'll only see
right here on 8 news now
carissa hernandez is a widow with three
young daughters
arthur nazari her 42 year old husband
died in july
after contracting covet 19. and it
breaks my heart
to see that they're going to have to
grow up without a dad
when she first shared her story with the
eye team she expressed
grief and also gratitude for the medical
team
i just want them to know that you know
how how much that meant to me into my
family
after the i-team called mountain view
hospital they were virtually
reunited looking at your faces you guys
helped pull me through it these are the
intensive care unit nurses who cared for
arter in his final moments
and the cardiologist who treated him
earlier on
it was really a shock to see someone who
was otherwise healthy
get so sick and you know that really
stuck with me visitors aren't allowed
inside covet patients rooms
marisa muraoka grabbed an ipad so
carissa and her girls
could watch the final efforts to save
archer's life
and then say goodbye i promised my
husband when
he was in the hospital when he first got
sick that i would never leave his side
you enabled me to fulfill that promise
to him
diane darris held arthur's hand she was
telling him it's okay baby
you'll be okay you're just gonna go to
sleep for a little bit
and that last communication to me it was
priceless
so to me that was an honor to be there
kelly kohler did chest compressions
there was not a dry eye in that coat
we uh
actually had to
sorry
[Music]
it was hard having the kids in the
background
i can still remember them screaming
daddy daddy not my daddy
and those are definitely some things
that
will keep me up at night at times but i
i
i think i made the right i made the
right decision by not sheltering them
from that those
moments um to us were
part of what kept the resuscitation
going like the efforts to keep
doing as much as we can going but also
knowing when it was time and to
communicate that to carissa and saying
you know it's time to let him go
a nurse herself at a different hospital
carissa says
she believes these healthcare workers
did everything they could
because i know in my heart and soul that
they did
a meeting like this isn't the norm
karissa sharing how she and her
daughters are coping months later
these normally stoic health care workers
sharing how much
artur's death stays with them my heart
just just dropped and
i just want to say i'm sorry i just hope
that people who are experiencing loss
are able to move forward as gracefully
and with as much strength as you have
all of you are angels that day whether
you know it or not vanessa murphy
8 news now
tells the i-team mountain view hospital
waived arter's medical bills back in
august
she says corporate staff learned about
the circumstances
artur lost his job before he died he had
three young children and carissa
is a health care worker